TERRY RYAN: This week, we're
talking about a wide range
of subjects in the cloud.
I'm Terry Ryan, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Kubernetes
Engine is a great place
to run your containers,
and running Windows
doesn't change that.
Check out this post for a
step by step guide to running
a Windows container on GKE.
And don't worry-- we've
got plenty of code samples
to give you a running start
in the right direction.
So copy, paste, and get
your Windows containers
running on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Moving some or all of
your business to the cloud
often comes with
a lot of benefits,
and that's certainly
true for data warehouses.
Still, there are challenges,
from upfront investment
to handling security risks
to making sure you only
move what you need to move.
This post discusses the
most frequent questions
that come up from our customers
and help you answer them.
Cloud functions and
other serverless options
work great when your
whole stack auto scales.
But what if your app
depends on APIs or databases
with rate limits or
connection pulls?
Don't worry.
In this post, we'll teach
you all the strategies
for making serverless play nice
with the rest of your stack,
from tweaking Mac's
instant settings,
leveraging Cloud Tasks,
using stateful storage,
or plugging in Cloud Pub/Sub.
We've even got a
decision tree for when
you need to use each strategy.
Fairness in data and
machine learning algorithms
is critical to designing safe
and responsible AI systems
from the ground up.
Learn how to apply
fairness analysis
at every step of the
model development process.
Then grab the code
samples and get
started using the What-If
Tool to produce ML models that
are fair for everyone.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or just see the full
list, check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see you in the cloud.